more and more americans consider
venturing outside despite heavy
government pressure the media continue
to push non-answers to reopening and a
dallas shop owner becomes a national
flashpoint i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
today's ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your online
activity should not be public protect
yourself at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all of the news in just
a moment everything coronavirus related
plus
the shooting of a black man in georgia
that is generating national headlines as
well it should we'll get to all of that
momentarily first these days we're
looking for ways to stay fit at home but
here's the thing exercise equipment it
can be very bulky it can take up a lot
of room and you think that you have to
buy all sorts of
giant exercise equipment in order for
you to stay in shape
this is just not true one of the easiest
ways to stay in shape people don't
really think about it but
you see you know boxers doing it and
people who train doing it
is jumping rope i mean really i've been
doing this for a very long time in the
crossfit community it is very
big to jump rope you don't actually have
to be a pro at jumping rope in order to
get fit while jumping rope this is where
cross rope comes in
cardio machines aren't exactly
motivating and again that price can add
up super fast and take up tons of room
in your apartment well cross rope will
let you get a killer full body workout
in just 30 minutes it combines the
intense cardio workout of jumping rope
with full body resistance training
crossrope is reinventing the home
workout experience i've tried this
myself it is awesome these weighted
ropes give better feedback
makes it easier for beginners to get
started and learn fast they're durable
steel ropes with ergonomic handles and
patented fast clip systems so you can
actually swap the rope weights when you
do one of their workouts you actually
work with several different types of
rows some heavier some not as heavy so
that you can go speed rope or you can go
slower and
it really works out all of your muscles
choose between their get or get strong
sets depending on your fitness goal by
using their fitness app track your
workout see a map of your progress on
the free cross rope app i've done it
myself again it is a great workout a
fantastic workout so
if you're ready for a new cardio and
full body home workout visit
crossrope.com
shapiro get up to 40 bucks off cross
rope sets plus free shipping when you
check out today at crossrope.com
shapiro that is
s-h-a-p-i-r-o-crossrope.com again that's
crossrope.com
shapiro honestly fantastic workout get
up to 40 bucks
off plus free shipping at crossroads.com
shapiro
okay so we'll get to all the coronavirus
news in just a second first
we need to talk about the biggest sort
of national flashpoint of the day and
that is the
shooting and and killing of ahmed arberi
i i apologize if i'm pronouncing his
name wrong 25 year old black man who was
killed in february after being chased by
two armed men who told police he looked
like a burglary suspect
according to the washington post here
the video is actually
available of the shooting it appears
that the video was taken
by a member of the basically the posse
of these of these two guys who were one
of whom was in
a retired cop and his son so
in the video what what you're about to
see and it's very graphic so if you
don't want to watch this then
by all means turn away if you're
listening to it i'll describe it for you
but basically what you're about to see
is this 25 year old black man who
appears to be jogging
and he's jogging down the road and then
right in front of him there is a white
pickup truck in the back of the white
pickup truck
is an older gentleman an older man who
is who is carrying a gun
and outside of the truck is his son
who's in his 30s and is carrying a
shotgun and this whole thing is being
filmed from behind
presumably by one of their friends
because why else would you just be
filming a random black guy running down
the road
okay so here is what the video shows
when we play the video and on there i
did so
you can see that what's happening right
here is our barry
jogging right he doesn't appear to be
sprinting away or sprinting sideways
he sort of moves toward the left side of
the truck then he proceeds to run around
the right side of the truck when he sees
he's being confronted and there's a man
there carrying a shotgun
and the man carrying the shotgun he
confronts the mount the shotgun
grabs the shotgun and then you can see
that they they get into a fight
and at that point the man with the
shotgun appears to either pull the
trigger or
or the gun is pulled and his fingers on
the trigger it and our barry is dead i
mean our barry is killed
in in the video it also appears and it's
hard to tell
that the man on the back of the shot on
the back of the the pickup truck
it looks like he takes a pot shot before
any shot is fired from the shotgun
although it's difficult to tell from the
video because the video
is kind of grainy so here is the
backstory on this
and these these the white guys who shot
the black guy
they were not prosecuted for two months
they were left to go free for two months
and that's where everybody is starting
to go crazy because they're saying okay
why for two months was nobody arrested
for all of this so here is the backstory
and then we'll go through
the various legal arguments on behalf of
first-degree murder versus second-degree
murder manslaughter
in this particular case whatever you say
the legal case here to put these guys in
in jail is
pretty strong and there are several
pieces i'm going to go through to talk
about that
today again it's on tape the tape is
is at least somewhat dispositive as to
what happened here if you were a man
running down the road and you were
confronted by people with guns and they
were blocking your way in an attempt to
stop you
it would not be out of your out of your
purview to run and try to
fight the guy with the gun to try and
get away right that they were literally
attempting to obstruct him it was not as
though they pulled him so their original
narrative as we'll see is that they
pulled the
pulled off to the side of him and asked
him to stop because they thought that he
had burglarized something
there was not a lot of evidence
apparently that they'd actually seen the
burglary in process which would change
the status here under law because you're
only allowed to pursue somebody and try
to arrest them if you actually see a
crime
in progress if you're going to make a
citizens arrest there's a national
citizens arrest law in the state of
georgia that does not appear to have
been fulfilled here
so they charge around the so they
stopped him looks like in the middle of
the road and called a friend
and the friend is filming this whole
thing and if you're that guy and you're
just running down the road
and you see somebody forget about race
for a second if you see somebody with a
shotgun and a guy in the back of the
pickup truck
with a handgun and they're attempting to
stop you and you've committed no crime
and you can't get around them what the
hell else are you supposed to do right
that guy actually has
an extraordinarily strong self-defense
stand your ground claim the jogger does
our berry does okay so here is the lead
up to to all of this this is according
to the new york times
ahmed are barry loved to run it was how
the 25 year old former
high school football standout stayed fit
his friend said it was not unusual to
see him running around the outskirts
of the small coastal georgia city near
where he lived but on a sunday afternoon
in february as mr arberry ran through a
suburban neighborhood of ranch houses
and moss draped oaks he passed a man
standing in his front yard who later
told the police that our barry looked
like a suspect in a string of break-ins
according to a police report the man
gregory mcmichael who's 64
called out to his son travis mcmichael
34 they grabbed their weapons a 357
magnum revolver and a shotgun
jumped into a truck and began following
mr arberry okay so as we will see
the the question is to whether they
actually witnessed a crime
in progress and then got active is
one of the operative questions here you
don't have the right to let's say that
three weeks ago you saw a
grainy videotape you say hey look i saw
a guy walk down the street looks just
like that suspect
in georgia you don't have the right to
go grab your gun and try to arrest that
guy you can't effectuate a citizens
arrest unless you watch a crime in
progress
and you are attempting to stop the crime
this will become an issue
stop stop they shouted at mr alberta we
want to talk to you moments later after
a struggle over the shotgun our barry
was killed
shot at least twice no one has been
charged or arrested in connection with
the february 23rd killing
the case has received little attention
beyond brunswick but it raised questions
in the community about racial profiling
because our berry was black
and the father and son are white and
about the interpretation of the state's
self-defense laws now again the
the level of the of the charge is going
to be at issue when this thing does go
to court because it will go to court
number one because how do you interpret
the first degree murder statute
they stopped dead in the middle of the
road if this was a false imprisonment
connected with a killing then it's
first-degree murder meaning
that if this is the equivalent of a
kidnapping because they had no evidence
that the guy actually committed a crime
and then they shot him then it's felony
murder if there was evidence that the
guy
had committed a crime or if they thought
he had committed a crime
reasonably right this is what the jury
is going to determine then
then the attempt to arrest him could end
up being something more akin to
manslaughter because
it's fairly obvious when you have
somebody viewing a situation like this
from behind that you don't actually
expect that it's going to end in
somebody getting shot
it makes no sense for these people's
allies to be tracking this guy down the
street
because they want to watch him get shot
on tape just so that these guys can get
indicted right the tape is the most
damning thing about this
if there had been no tape it would be
very difficult to indict because all you
would have is the accounts of the people
involved
and that would be again very difficult
on the basis of evidence
on evidence alone the tape is the most
damning thing about anything
in this in this entire compendium effect
our berry was killed three days before
the anniversary of the 2012 killing of
trayvon martin the unarmed
african-american teenager whose
confrontation with the florida
neighborhood watch captain george
zimmerman helped ignite the black lives
matter movement and
it is important to distinguish the fact
patterns of these particular cases in
that particular case
there was controversy because zimmerman
again followed trayvon martin by
zimmerman's testimony which again there
was no tape
tape would have been very helpful in the
george zimmerman case there's no tape in
that case
zimmerman testified that he followed
martin then he turned around and then
martin confronted him and then martin
was on top of him by witness testimony
beating his head into the pavement there
was a struggle over the gun and he shot
martin that is a different fact pattern
than this one where you have two people
lying in wait
for the guy coming down the road and
then the guy
on basic self-defense grounds attempts
to defend himself
also as we'll see there's all sorts of
of racial stuff
that came up in the zimmerman case where
the media basically lied about zimmerman
they suggested that he was clearly doing
this because he was a racist
they suggested that he was a white
person even though he was actually
hispanic and then they termed him a
white hispanic they suggested that there
was no evidence that he'd actually been
hit by martin when in fact he had a
broken nose but there are all sorts of
complicating factors
in the george zimmerman case and that
case was overcharged by the prosecution
if they charged him with manslaughter
fairly decent shot they would have
convicted him but when it comes to this
particular case to get back to the fact
pattern here
according to documents obtained by the
new york times a prosecutor who had the
case for a few weeks told the police the
pursuers had acted within the scope of
georgia's citizens arrest statute and
that travis mcmichael who held the
shotgun had acted
out of self-defense the police report
doesn't mention whether our berry was in
possession of a weapon apparently he was
not
the prosecutor who wrote the letter was
again george barnhill who was the
district attorney for george's way cross
judicial circuit and had recused himself
from the case this month
after our barry's family complained he
had a conflict of interest a prosecutor
from another county
was then put in charge and then he
decided that this thing will go to a
grand jury
yesterday so the the fact pattern
is obviously in dispute here but as
we'll see we'll go through
the full analysis of the fact pattern
momentarily the fact pattern cuts in
favor of a of an indictment at the very
very least
friends and family say that our barry
was exercising
one of his friends said everybody in the
community knows he runs others contend
our berry was up to no good on the day
of the shooting apparently moments
before the chase a neighbor a neighbor
in satilla shores called
9-1-1 telling the dispatcher a black man
in a white t-shirt
was inside a house that was under
construction and only partially closed
in
and he's running right now the man told
the dispatcher there he goes right now
now again
that is not a burglary okay like being
on a construction site where there is
nothing worth stealing is not a burglary
have you ever walked in an open
construction site i have virtually
everyone i know has
you're walking around a neighborhood you
want to see how they're constructing a
house and you walk into the construction
site that is not
a crime okay that's certainly not a
crime where you get to chase someone
down and then hold them at bay
because you're because you're waiting
for the cops to come
in his letters to the police barnhill
noted that our berry had a criminal past
court
court records show that our barry was
convicted of shoplifting and violating
probation in 2018.
five years earlier according to the
brunswick news he was indicted on
charges he took a handgun to a high
school basketball game
none of which is supremely relevant to
what happened in this particular case
you bring a gun to a high school
basketball game five years beforehand
that has no relevance as to why these
particular people are trying to block
your particular way on this particular
highway
just going through the fact pattern even
if our barry committed a property crime
on the afternoon he was killed
activists and family members said it
would not have warranted a chase by
armed neighbors and then we get into the
racial issue right
our barry's mother said she believed the
men had judged her son by the hit by a
skin color she does not believe he
committed any crimes that day if he had
she said
he should have been handled by the
police now i tend to agree it should
have been handled by the police when we
get into the racial angle here
that's where things start to start to go
sideways the reason i say that is
because
certainly you can interpret this as a
racial shooting it's two it's it's
three white men apparently confronting a
young black man
in disputed circumstances and then
killing him right i mean then he's shot
the question as always when it comes to
overzealous people getting involved in
cases like this which is what it appears
to be again they had this on tape
what it appears to is it about race is
it about
racism against a black man running in a
largely white area
or if the guy were hispanic and were
running through the neighborhood
would they have made the call if it had
been a guy who looked like he was
a white guy who who they were suspicious
of would they have made the same call
in other words is it possible that these
are overzealous cops who are overzealous
cops since that's not the guy whose next
cop right
and very often you do see this i mean
the this is the point that adam corolla
has made before that if you're a black
person in america with the terrible
history of law enforcement with black
americans if
if you were pulled over for speeding as
a black man and you didn't really think
that you were speeding
and the white officer kim was rude to
you you might assume that it was because
the officer was a racist because adam
carol is a white guy he says
i would just assume that the officer is
an a-hole right so it's unclear in this
particular case whether it's racial the
same thing by the way was true
with regard to the george zimmerman case
in the george zimmerman case
there were several investigations
including a federal investigation by the
eric holder justice department that
found no evidence of racial intent
in that particular case we don't
actually know whether there was racial
intent here the attempt to blow this up
into a racial narrative
maybe right maybe but we don't have the
evidence of that now that does not
change
whether these guys should be indicted so
that brings us to the state
of the law okay so there are a couple of
different pieces on this that are worth
going through one
is from my friend david french who is a
very very good lawyer over at the
dispatch
he says that the the killers should be
arrested and tried for murder
he says let's let's walk through the
events and then he goes through all of
the evidence we'll go through all of the
evidence
in just one second and we'll go through
sort of the legal case and then we'll
get to the broader political
ramifications because one thing is
obviously true if the
if the media can treat a terrible
incident like this
as an incident that indicts america more
broadly along the lines of racism it
becomes a national story and it doesn't
stop being a national story
and the media encourages that if it
turns out that everybody's like okay
this is a bad shooting
and maybe it was racist and maybe it
wasn't but these guys should be
at least tried then the controversy goes
away how do i know this because that's
exactly what happened in the case
of walter scott who's the black man in
south carolina who was gunned down by a
police officer the police officer lied
about it it was on tape the police
officer ended up
his name was michael slagel he ended up
in jail for 20 years
no controversy whatsoever because
everybody basically agreed you do a bad
thing you should go to jail
it is only when the media can turn it
into a broader indictment of american
racism
that the media are interested in the
story so the fact that there seems to be
pretty broad and wide agreement that
these guys at the very least should go
to a grand jury and be indicted and then
get their day in court
it kind of cuts against the idea that
americans are deeply desirous
of protecting people on the basis of a
possible racial killing we'll get to
that
in just one second first let's talk
about the reality which is that it is
very difficult to see a doctor
these days on average people have to
wait around 29 days to see a doctor in
major u.s cities that was before covet
19.
well if you're dealing with a condition
like erectile dysfunction or hair loss
or cold sores you want treatment asap
that's why our friends at roman have
spent years building a digital platform
that can connect you with a doctor
licensed in your state
all from the comfort of home just grab
your phone or computer complete a free
online visit
you will hear back from a us licensed
physician within 24 hours
if the doctor decides that treatment is
right for you roman's pharmacy can ship
your medication to you with free two-day
shipping
you also get free unlimited follow-ups
with your doctor anytime you have
questions or want to adjust your
treatment plan
with roman there are no commitments and
you can cancel anytime
you know if you've got an embarrassing
medical condition it shouldn't be
embarrassing it should be something you
go get solved
now you're not in control your medical
condition but you can get in control of
your medical condition
at getroman.com if you're struggling
with ed hair loss cold sores other
issues go to getroman.com for a free
online visit and free two day shipping
that is
dot com slash ben for that free online
visit and free two-day shipping once
more getroman.com for the free online
visit
as well as free two-day shipping okay so
as i say my friend david french over at
the dispatch has a good piece on this
he he he says that there was a 911 call
and it's unclear who made the call
it's not clear who made the call so this
makes a difference because if you
witness a crime in the state of georgia
by statute then you're allowed to
attempt a citizen's arrest
but if you are just somebody who heard
about it third hand from somebody not
the same thing
right if my producer colton sees
somebody committing a crime and then he
calls me and i have not witnessed the
crime and then he says that guy's
running down your street you should go
do something about it
no citizens arrest for me right that's
not something that i get to do
so in the call the guy makes it clear
there was no media breaking he said
there's a guy in the house right now
it's under construction the man gave her
an address
the dispatcher and the dispatcher says
you said someone's breaking into it
right now
and the man says no it's all open it's
under construction okay so right now
it's very obvious that the person is not
witnessing a crime in progress
right which is very different from the
original story we were told by the
prosecutor who recommended not charging
he said oh we witnessed a crime in
process
that's what was happening so georgia's
citizens arrest statue kicks in
not not by this 911 call it doesn't the
dispatcher says
that's fine i'll get the police out
there i just need to know what he was
doing wrong was he just on the premises
and not supposed to be
the next sentence the guy says he's been
caught on camera a bunch at night it's
kind of an ongoing thing
the man building the house has got heart
issues i think he's not going to finish
it and the dispatch says okay that's
fine you said he was a male in a black
t-shirt
and the guy says white t-shirt black guy
white t-shirt he's done run
into the neighborhood again so now the
guy is trying to
link this our berry fellow with
grainy video footage from prior crimes
again none of this is immediate as we'll
see that makes a difference the georgia
law is you have to immediately witness a
crime it is not i saw a tape three weeks
ago of somebody shoplifting
now that guy appears in my neighborhood
and he's walking around open
construction site no this does not count
minutes later another person calls 9-1-1
the guy says i'm out here it's attila
shores there's a black male
running down the street okay well last i
checked a black male running down the
street is not actually a crime that's
just a description of a human being
running down the street
so how that qualifies as worthy of you
need to stop him and threaten him with a
gun i have no idea
and the dispatcher says where it's
attila shores the man says i don't know
what street we're on
and then he says stop he can be heard
shouting watch that stop damn it stop
the call goes blank for several minutes
the dispatcher tries to
reach the color and the call eventually
hangs up at some point in the sequence
says david french
a man named gregory mcmichael saw
erberry allegedly hauling ass down the
street
not clear if mcmichael is one of the 911
callers
mcmichael told police there had been
several break-ins in the neighborhood
and the suspect was caught on
surveillance video he grabbed his 357
his son grabbed a shotgun they began
pursuing our berry in their vehicle so a
few things that are important here to
note
one there were not at least a reported
speed of breaking since attila shores
from january 1st to february 23rd by
local newspaper coverage there was a
grand total of one
one count from one police report on
break-in in the area
again this is rather distinguishing from
the case in george zimmerman's
neighborhood in florida
where there had been a huge spate of
break-ins that everybody acknowledged
according to police reports
from the police report it appears there
were two vehicles and three individuals
involved in the chase mcmichael said he
tried to cut off our berry on the road
so did an individual named roddy
mcmichael says he then got into the bed
of the pickup truck and continued the
pursuit
here's how the police report described
the fatal encounter mcmichael stated
they saw the unidentified mail and
shouted stop stop we want to talk to you
mcmichael stated they pulled up beside
the mail and shouted stop again at which
time travis exited the truck with a
shotgun mcmichael stated the
unidentified male began to violently
attack travis and the two men then
started fighting over the shotgun
at which point travis fired a shot and a
second later there was a second shot
mcmichael stated the male fell
face down on the pavement with his hand
under his body mcmichael stated he
rolled the man over to see if the male
had a weapon okay so there are a few
things about this particular police
report that
do not jibe with the facts one it
appears that just if you play the tape
you can hear three shots not two
second the notion that he pulled up next
to him is not true that the
vehicle is waiting directly in the
center of the road right so that so that
part is not true
so as david french points out the video
doesn't depict mcmichael pulling up
beside our barry but instead shows him
waiting blocking the road with his truck
our barry changes direction to avoid the
truck
travis mcmichael moves to intercept our
barry while holding a shotgun the two
scuffled
and then travis fires three shots
although it's not clear again whether
travis fires three shots or whether
somebody
in the back of the truck fires a shot
first and then there are two shots fired
from the shotgun not not totally clear
but you can hear three shots not two
so as as david french points out the
brunswick news
noted only one burglary had been
reported to local police between january
1st
and the day of the shooting also
mcmichael is a former police detective
and investigator for the brunswick
district attorney's office
according to the new york times the
first district attorney jackie johnson
recused herself because
mcmichael had worked with her a second
district attorney stepped away from the
case
also because he knew mcmichael so his
argument was the three men were in hot
pursuit of a burglary suspect with solid
first-hand probable cause
in the effort to execute a citizen's
arrest and he says this was just open
carrying weapons is lawful in georgia
the shooting occurred only after our
barrier attacked mcmichael and tried to
grab his shotgun which again goes to the
question as to whether this was a a
premeditated
murder in the sense that they were
waiting to ambush him which it does not
appear to be
or whether they were waiting to arrest
him and they had no right to arrest him
and so
it was it was a shooting that was
combined with false imprisonment which
would amount to felony murder that's the
case the french is going to make
georgia law does indeed permit a person
to execute a citizen's arrest but in
very narrow circumstances
the relevant false arrest statute holds
that quote a private person may arrest
an offender if the offense is committed
in his presence
or within his immediate knowledge if the
offense is a felony and the offender is
escaping or attempting to escape
a private person may arrest him upon
reasonable and probable cause of
suspicion
once the citizen's arrest is properly
made georgia law requires the citizen to
take the suspect before a judicial
officer or a peace officer
without any any unnecessary delay it's
also true that an unlawful attempt to
take and hold a person is itself a crime
false imprisonment
moreover according to georgia case law
you can't use a citizen's arrest statute
to question a suspect
in fact stating an intention to question
a suspect can be evidence that the
individual claiming a right to make a
citizen's arrest
is uncertain and did not have immediate
knowledge the victim had been a
perpetrator of the alleged crime
so if you actually apply the law of the
fact says david french on the day our
barry died a 911 caller said a man
matching arbury's description was
walking inside a vacant construction
site
another caller said there's a black male
running down the street gregory
mcmichael claimed he recognized darberry
from surveillance video after several
break-ins in the neighborhood
the only offense committed in anyone's
presence is the report of a person
walking into a construction site
if that merits mounting up an armed
three-person two-vehicle posse to chase
a man in broad daylight menacing with
weapons
many of us are lucky to be alive and
free
the other possible argument is that in
the unspecified video footage
the break-ins constituted immediate
knowledge that a crime had been
committed days or weeks ago
and that an alleged older crime provided
them with reasonable and probable
grounds of suspicion
but that would be a pretty large scale
extension
of the law georgia case law says past
incidents may not justify
present citizen citizen pursuit a 2000
georgia court of appeals opinion says
the term within his immediate knowledge
enables a private citizen to use any of
his senses to obtain knowledge that an
offense
is being committed also again there are
problems with the police report
now does this mean that these guys get
convicted without a trial of course not
of course not it means they get a trial
it means that this will go to a grand
jury and then they will have a defense
and then all of the facts will come out
and then we will know exactly what their
motivation was and we will know exactly
what went down and what was the crime
they were attempting to report
and how all of this went down and so to
say in dispositive fashion these guys
deserve to go to jail again
based on the evidence that we have seen
the answer seems like yes but we're
gonna have to have a trial right
and that's what trials are for that's
why they're going to indict with the
grand jury
the broader question is why there was no
arrest in the first place why was it
that there was no arrest
on the original grounds right that's a
serious question why for two months
did they sit on this thing and that
appears the question there is was that
based on racism or was that based on the
fact that every prosecutor in town knew
this mcmichael guy and they were like
okay well you know he worked with us
over at the cops office and we're going
to let it go
right this is just an insider question
that gains additional relevance when you
get to the racial aspect of the case
which of course is what
the media are jumping on and maybe the
racial aspect of the case is the key
aspect of the case but
there's just a solid case that the
racial aspect of the case is secondary
to generalized law enforcement
overzealousness or ex-law enforcement
overzealous
zealousness combined with an insider
nature for people who worked with law
enforcement in the first place
so we'll get to that in just one second
first
let us talk about the fact that now is
not a great time to go to the auto parts
store you want to stay home but your car
is broken you need to fix it
number one why would you ever go to the
auto parts store where you can get
exactly the part you need
at the best available price at
rockauto.com they have
a huge selection they have the best
available prices they're not going to
give you a separate price if you're a
professional versus a do-it-yourselfer
instead go to rockauto.com they're
reliably low same for professionals
do-it-yourselfers prices why spend up to
twice as much for the same parts
the rockauto.com catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
there's amazing selection reliably low
prices all the parts your car will ever
need
rockauto.com so head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
shapiro in there how did you hear about
us box
so they know that we sent you again
write shapiro in that how did you care
about us box so they know
that we that they sent you that we sent
you go to rockauto.com you'll be able to
get the best available parts
i mean really and you're gonna get it
the best price the intro web it's an
amazing thing
go check out rockauto.com right now
don't pay too much for auto parts and
why leave your house right now go to
rockauto.com instead write shapiro in
there how did you hear about us box okay
so
back to the the story in this particular
case and this is where
the media start to become an issue
so it is good that there was public
attention brought to this case by the
media that is a good thing
because it means that what appeared to
be a bunch of people in the da's office
who were friends with the guy at issue
that those people are not the people who
end up prosecuting the case
right that is a good thing we want to
make sure that law enforcement actually
does its job
but it is also true that the media in
cases like this immediately tend to jump
to this is a racial case
first and foremost that this is a case
of race this is
undergirded by tweets from people like
lebron james lebron james tweeted out
we're literally hunted every day every
time we step outside a step foot outside
the comfort of our homes
can't even go for a damn jog man like
what the f man are you kidding me
no man for real are you kidding me i'm
sorry ahmad rest in paradise and my
prayers and blessings
sent to the sent to thee okay so this
has 302
000 likes now statistically speaking it
is not true
that black people are hunted every time
they step outside the comfort of their
homes there's a reason we know the names
of people to whom this has happened
right it's just not statistically true
that black people are hunted by white
people all across the country
that that was true for a long time in
american history right that was true
during large swaths of jim crow when the
kkk was basically a legal terror
organization that is not true today
it is just not true that white people
are running around the country willingly
hunting now black people it's not
statistically true
at the same time it is very important
that law enforcement do its job
specifically in order to fight
perceptions like this now that doesn't
mean
that you should make up cases against
people god forbid we have due process of
law in this country but
it looks bad when you have local law
enforcement not taking seriously enough
allegations that have taped to back them
like this now the legal issue in this
case
really is gonna come down to did they
witness this guy commit a crime
if they witness this guy commit a crime
and then they tried to stop him
okay then then it can very easily be
argued
that this is a terrible case in which
our barry
our barry was acting in his own
self-defense and once he grabs the gun
then the guy who shot him was also
acting in mutual self-defense but that
that really depends on whether the
citizen's arrest was justified in the
first place if the citizen's arrest was
just we're suspicious of this guy
running down the road because we think
he looked like the guy from two days ago
and we're vigilantes and we're not gonna
call the cops
and if we do call the cops we're not
gonna wait on them we need to go stop
this right now
then you end up in the case of felony
imprisonment
felony murder right which is which is
the case that david french is making
and the statute again in georgia is
fairly clear the statute
is fairly straightforward that you have
to witness the immediate crime
but when the media immediately jumped to
we know for a fact that this was white
guys chasing down a black guy because it
was a black guy in a white neighborhood
and they decided to go and shoot him
that day
again the evidence doesn't support the
idea that these guys were like out to
gun down a black guy that day it does
support the idea
i think much more obviously that these
were overzealous
wannabe cops and ex-cops who decided
that they were going to
be vigilantes that day and then this
thing went wrong and you are guilty for
that
right you're guilty for that that is a
thing that you are guilty for under the
criminal laws of the state of georgia
which is why this is going to go to
grand jury and all the facts are going
to come out
but to suggest on the basis of of the
case
itself that black people are gunned down
every day in the united states
that black people are at tremendous
day-to-day risk from normal
white people walking down the road
that's just it's not true which is why
again this is getting all sorts of
national attention if this were true
that this were happening every single
day
you know what the news doesn't report on
stuff that happens every single day
the reason that this is an outlier case
and is getting all sorts of attention is
number one because we have tape and
number two
because it is a really bad fact pattern
it's a really bad situation
so i would urge everybody to wait for
all the facts to come in
i'm glad that the video is out there and
that we can all look at it i i
i've been a fan of dash cams on police
officers for a long time
and cameras on police officers for a
very long time
it seems to me based on this fact
pattern that it is completely correct
for the prosecutor's office to put in
a grand jury indictment i do not know
trey gowdy said the same thing on fox
news yesterday i do not understand
why for two months there was no
indictment put forward no grand jury
case
they will get a defense they will have a
chance to defend themselves in court
that's the way this is supposed to work
the real issue to me beyond the actual
fact pattern of the case
is why the prosecutors didn't go forward
and
the implication is gonna be they didn't
go forward because it was white guy
shooting a black man they don't care
it seems to me that the much more likely
scenario is this didn't go forward with
an indictment in the first place because
everybody was friends with the guy who
did the shooting
right that this was that basically it
was an insider problem in which you had
a former member of law enforcement who
knew all the das
and they were like would billy bob over
here would jim have have really
gone out and just randomly shot somebody
probably probably he was fine probably
it was not a big deal
which again is not the way that you
pursue law enforcement and it does
undermine it does undermine the
credibility of law enforcement
because baseless or not the widespread
perception that black people
are in widespread fashion targeted by
white law enforcement in this country
that is undermined that that perception
is underscored
every time the the law enforcement
apparatus
does not actually go forward with an
indictment in cases where it appears an
indictment
seems to be warranted so that that's
that's where we stand on this
and i'm i'm glad that a grand jury case
will go forward on this and and these
people should have a chance to defend
themselves because everybody should have
a chance to defend themselves
it appears to me that david french's
case is pretty strong uh that this looks
like a felony
murder based on people being vigilantes
and and
violation of the law okay now we're
going to get to everything coronavirus
related because
again nobody has a plan it's the
kobayashi maru problem from star trek
nobody has a plan and the idea that if
you
look at various plans that you're
somehow very bad and very evil this
continues to be the pervading
attitude of many in the media and that's
just not appropriate we'll get to that
in just a minute first
let's talk for a second about knowing
what's going on in your neighborhood
we're home more than usual these days
but it's still hard to keep a close eye
on things i've got my kids running all
over my property they're people dropping
off packages all the time because we
have to
buy all of our groceries remote well you
want to know when people are at your
front door or what they're doing at your
front door
ring is on a mission to make
neighborhoods safer their home security
products are designed to give you peace
of mind around the clock from video
doorbells and security cameras to smart
security lighting and alarm systems
ring has everything you need to make
sure your family and belongings are safe
and secure
anytime anywhere and with the all-new
ring video doorbell 3 you can keep an
even closer eye
on things than ever before ring gives
you protection at every corner video
doorbells let you answer the door
check in on your home anytime keep an
eye on your doorstep or speak to
delivery people when you can't come to
the door
with the outside with outdoor security
cameras you can check in on every part
of your house and never miss a moment
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kit when you go to ring.com
the welcome kit includes the ring video
doorbell 3 and chime pro it's all you
need to start building custom security
for your home today just go to ring.com
that is ring.com we've had ring on our
property for a long time makes us feel a
lot safer
go check it out ring.com okay we can get
to everything coronavirus related in a
second first
got to take a moment to tell you about
the magical all-access insider tier
of daily wire membership the all-access
insider membership it's our premium
level of membership all access members
get the benefits of our other membership
tiers including an ad free website
experience
access to all of our live broadcasts and
show library access to the show's
mailbags and the full three hours of the
ben shapiro show along with dedicated
editorials
from mwah all access members also get
other amazing benefits
including the singular irreplaceable
leftist tiers tumbler much sought after
they also get to join the live exclusive
online q as we have a new discussion
feature available on both the website
and the daily wire app and
you get to participate in all access
live that is our brand new interactive
programming
featuring featuring one of us one of
your daily wire hosts as we hang out
with you each night
8 pm eastern 5 p.m pacific i will be
joining you tomorrow night so head on
over to dailywire.com
subscribe to watch me wear a t-shirt and
sing show tunes join daily ware's all
access club
with a new membership or upgrade got 10
off with coupon code shapiro that is
dailywire.com
subscribe we will see you there this is
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show for the nation
as you say the media tend to traffic and
outrage on all stories when it comes to
this story in georgia
the outrageous part is presumably that
it wasn't put in front of a grand jury
the media are attempting to turn this
into again a broader racial narrative
about the united states
this is why if the american people
basically react to this by saying okay
the law
the law should take its course here then
the media simply go away
because then they can't make the
argument this is about broader american
tolerance for racism or for bad shoots
right that will go away well the media
are trafficking in
all sorts of outrage when it comes to
covid 19
as well they continue to claim that
recognizing the reality which is that
nothing major may change with regard to
kova 19 this just may be the new reality
meaning that the risk levels in society
exist no no new therapeutics
no vaccine and maybe by the way maybe
years before we develop a vaccine like
the fastest people have ever developed a
coronavirus vaccine in the past
has been like four years so the idea
that we're gonna do this in six months
and that it's going to be
extraordinarily effective
the flu vaccine which is a pretty
effective vaccine is only 45
effective to reach herd immunity you
really do need this thing to be about 70
effective so it needs to be super
effective it needs to be applied in
widespread fashion so it may just be
that this is the new risk level
in life and if this is the new risk
level in life then the question becomes
okay why are we not protecting people
who are the most vulnerable and then
moving toward opening up very very
quickly but the media seem to have
an interest in claiming that lockdowns
are the best available policy
and that if you oppose the lockdowns if
you say guys there's some actual cost to
what's going on here then you're very
very bad so here's an example check todd
yesterday
on msnbc says is the federal government
considering surrendering to this virus
i have a question what would fighting
the virus look like really i mean we're
devoting extraordinary resources to
private research and development we are
funding
a huge testing regimen across the
country states are doing this
what do what does he mean surrender is
it a surrender when you just say listen
we don't know what's going to happen
from here on in but we are going to have
to plan for the reality which is that
maybe nothing changes here i i
understand that you want to yell at the
government over changes that may never
happen
but i i've yet to hear an actual policy
put forward by anybody who's advocating
for lockdowns that looks like anything
realistic here's chuck todd
again sort of just outrage jinning
the federal government led by president
trump considering for a lack
of a better word surrendering to this
virus with more than 70 000 americans
dead the president is telling the public
that the country
must reopen even if it means more death
but he doesn't have a plan for doing
that the uncertainty surrounding the
white house's strategy
which we seem to utter about on a daily
basis comes into numerous warning signs
that we're not anywhere near ready to
safely reopen the country from a public
health standpoint
or a consumer confidence standpoint okay
there is no
there is no standard that has been put
forward by anybody that says what safely
reopening the country looks like
what does safely reopening the country
look like now according to the media it
means 50 million tests today and that
ain't gonna happen
it's just not going to happen that is
more tests than are carried out on any
day in america's entire medical system
for all diseases combined so what you're
talking about is just nonsense
and when you say america is not ready to
safely reopen you have not set the
standard for what safely reopening looks
like so
how the hell do you know when america is
ready to safely reopen this is how you
end up with the stupidity of joe biden
tweeting out last night
and joe biden did tweet out last time we
have joe biden's tweet here he tweeted
i've said it before and i'll say it
again
no one is expendable no life is worth
losing to add one more point to the dao
so this is just such a false binary the
idea here is that somehow if you want to
reopen all you care about is your dow
jones industrial average stock market
such absolute utter crap first of all i
have a question for joe biden does he
plan on ending death
is that his plan that he's going to ban
death because when he says
no life is worth losing to add one more
point to the dow so presumably
he's just going to ban death because it
turns out your risk of dying
increases every time you go out the door
with or without coven 19. so presumably
we should all just be locked down in our
homes forever and the government
can you know just make money appear out
of thin air
like what the hell is he talking about
that's not setting up a standard
the deliberate attempt to avoid setting
up any standards for reopening at all
is the mark of of political uh of
political dishonesty it's it's true
political dishonesty it's the same thing
as andrew cuomo doing the
i i will give you my answer as to
whether we think that this thing is
going to
well we have to answer seriously the
calculation between cost
and benefit and i will give you my
answer every life is priceless it's like
it's not giving the answer you're
lighting the question dude you're
avoiding having the actual discussion
that needs to be had because guess what
the costs here are pretty damned
extraordinary
pretty damned extraordinary okay the
fact is
that the united states lost another 3.2
million jobs we're now up to 33
million jobs lost and this is
disproportionately hitting minority
americans for all the people saying all
the people who want to reopen are rich
and white
weird because it seems to me like all
the rich and white people in the media
don't want to reopen
and those people are disproportionately
rich and white it seems to me that all
the liberals in california who are
disproportionately rich and white in the
in the malibu enclaves they're fine with
it staying shut it's the people who
actually need to work who are getting
jacked
and those people are disproportionately
poor in minority according to
the associated press people of color
have not only been hit harder by the
deadly coronavirus than have americans
overall
they're also bearing the brunt of the
pandemic's financial impact according to
a recent survey
the poll found 61 percent of hispanic
americans say they experienced some kind
of household income loss
as a result of the outbreak including
job losses unpaid leave pay cuts and
fewer scheduled hours that is compared
with 46 percent of americans overall
37 percent of latinos 27 percent of
black americans
say they have been unable to pay at
least one type of bill as a result of
the coronavirus outbreak
i mean these are extraordinary
extraordinary numbers the survey which
was conducted in mid-april
found that 21 of hispanics have been
unable to make a rent or mortgage
payment as a result of the outbreak
23 have been unable to pay a credit card
bill
15 of black americans have been unable
to pay a credit card bill
so the notion that if you want to reopen
it's because you dislike minorities
you're gonna have to explain that one to
me you're also
going to have to explain to me how you
solved all the problems joe biden by
simply declaring that that
you're going to end death because guess
what nearly a fifth
of young children according to brookings
institute a fifth of young children are
not getting enough to eat
the rate is three times higher than in
2008 at the worst of the great recession
when food runs short parents often skip
meals to keep children fed a survey of
households with children 12 and under
found 17.4
reported that children themselves were
not eating enough compared with 5.7
during the great recession so you're
telling me that it's bad to reopen and
then you won't set any standard for
reopening
deeply irresponsible nonsense deeply
deeply irresponsible nonsense
now this does not mean that on the other
side it is worthwhile to question
the death toll of the virus so there's a
report that president trump is
complaining to advisers about the way
the coronavirus deaths are being
calculated here's the reality this thing
is deadly it's killing a lot of people
you don't have to downplay the number of
people being killed in order to
point out that we simply cannot continue
this way and that the people who are
being disproportionately harmed by this
are people who are impoverished people
who are already living
on the brink it is also important to
recognize here
that if we started by protecting just
the nursing homes we would have lowered
the deadliness of this thing
dramatically according to a report in
the hartford quran nearly 90
of all coronavirus deaths in connecticut
last week were nursing home patients
90 so andrew cuomo and company who keep
saying every life is precious but didn't
defend the nursing homes in fact
forced by law nursing homes to take back
people who had kova 19
well done everybody so is trump wrong is
he bad when he says we can't keep the
country closed down for years
of course he's not wrong of course he's
not bad he's exactly right and everybody
knows it every single person knows it in
america they're just the people who
refuse to recognize it
because it's a lot easier to play
righteous indignation about reopening
when you don't when you ever set a
standard that can never be met for
reopening here is trump saying we can't
keep the country closed down for years
which of course is true
we can't keep our country closed down
for
years and we have to do something and
hopefully that won't be the case john
but it could very well be the case
you won't be locked in a house and some
people
should stay if you're over a certain age
but we have to get our country open
again and you see it look you cover it
people want to go back you're going to
have a problem if you don't do it
hundred percent correct but this means
he's very bad and the federal government
is abandoning abandoning
their efforts to fight covet 19. okay
again let's get to a reality
do you think that something magical is
going to happen now really that's the
question do you think there's a
therapeutic that comes in
and reduces the death rate of this thing
by 50 60
do you think that hurt immunity is going
to be achieved by vaccination
and if so when and for how long do you
expect that people are going to be able
to continue to exist
this way in fact it turns out that
the people who are being diagnosed with
new cases in new york are not being
diagnosed by going out in public
andrew cuomo pointed this out yesterday
which is an incredible incredible
admission here's andrew cuomo basically
acknowledging
that the lockdowns may have slowed the
spread of the virus but right now the
spread of the virus is entirely
happening
inside the lockdown here is it here's
cuomo
where are those new cases still coming
from
because we've done everything we can to
close down
how are you still generating 600 new
cases
every day where are they coming from
these people were literally at home
uh two percent of car services nine
percent were driving their own
vehicle only four percent were taking
public transportation two percent were
walking
84 percent were at home
literally were they working
no you have two categories
confirmed deaths
and then probable
or presumed deaths
and they list numbers in both
categories some people combine the two
confirmed deaths and presumed deaths
and have one number some people keep
them separate
and then they're often reported
separately or they're reported together
so does this really speak to the
efficacy of the
of of the lockdown when the spread is
still happening and it's happening
inside houses
what is the efficacy of that meanwhile
you know over in sweden which again the
left is loving to hate on these days
over in sweden
important to note that they're actually
bending the curve back down so the daily
death toll has been dropping again
in sweden which means that as they
approach herd immunity presumably
that the daily death toll is going to
drop and here's the question i just
don't know what the alternatives are
i seriously don't know like we can
debate on the level of reopening whether
it should be 50
full or whether we should be doing
control the avalanche in which we
actually just
basically encourage people to pursue
hurt immunity right there's all sorts of
discussions we can have on that one
thing is absolutely true these lockdowns
cannot continue this way and the
american people know it
and this is why it's become such a
flashpoint this case of this dallas
salon owner
so we talked about this yesterday
there's a dallas salon owner who defied
a court order and opened up
and she was jailed for her name was
shelley luther and the judge
asked her to apologize if she would
apologize and say she would never go out
without the state's permission again
then he would basically wave her
sentence and she was like no i'm not
doing that i have to feed my kids
well as it becomes obvious that kids are
going to have to be fed
nobody is going to go along with the
government's
order here because basically the logic
went something like this government says
you need a lockdown for 30 days
everybody's like okay i guess we'll do
that and then it became you need to lock
down for 60 days and we said well
how am i going to feed my kids and the
government was like okay well we will
pay all your bills and then
all these people couldn't feed their
kids we're calling up the government the
line was busy
and so they said okay i guess we're
gonna have to go back to work because
like seriously i need to feed my kids
and the government was like yeah but if
you go back to work we're gonna put you
in jail
does that sound like that's sustainable
in any way shape or form
here was the attorney for shelly luther
talking yesterday about the fact that
she's going to end up in jail while
criminals are being released onto the
streets
she committed the actual crime of heresy
against the city of dallas and its
oligarchy that decided that real
criminals could go to jail
but people who were heretics or people
who were real criminals could be let out
but the heretics could go to jail and
and he demanded that she admit she was
being selfish
and being offensive and apologize to
everybody he actually said
i want you to apologize for being
selfish and so
of course she wasn't being selfish she's
just trying to earn a dollar
okay so in amazing news i mean this is
how americans operate and this is
you can see where the passion is right
now she is raised her legal defense fund
has raised half a million dollars
not only that the texas lieutenant
governor dan patrick he offered to pay
the 7 000
fine and to do her jail time for her
yesterday the attorney general of the
state of texas said this is ridiculous
said that we we cannot we cannot jail
people for this he said i find it
outrageous and out of touch that during
this national pandemic a judge in a
county that actually released hardened
criminals for fear of contracting kova
would jail a mother for operating her
hair salon in an attempt to put food on
her family's table
the trial judge did not need to lock up
shelley luther his order is a shameful
abuse of judicial discretion he should
release ms luther immediately
even the governor of texas greg abbott
came out and he said
probably this lady shouldn't be in jail
that's like the last available
that's the last available thing now
things are going to get really rough
here they are because the fact is
human beings were not built for this
they are not built for this
human beings were not built for
interminable lockdown they were not
built for social distancing
and as it becomes clear that there is no
relief in sight that there is no
therapeutic
that there is no actual that there is no
actual vaccine
on the way anytime in the near future
that all the talk about yeah we're
working on all these vaccines and it's
going to be the cure on all this that is
speculative at best
really at best people are going to begin
saying okay i am young and i am healthy
i'm 40 i'm 40 years old and i have no
pre-existing conditions my chances of
death are seven and ten thousand
you know what i'm going to work you know
what i'm going to a ball game
you know what i'm getting back to daily
life because people have a unique
capacity
to absorb terrible things happening to
them their lives then move on like
nothing is happening
this is a grand shock there is some good
news the good news is we do know how to
protect the nursing homes we do know how
to protect the most vulnerable in our
society and
we have the capacity as independent
individuals to protect ourselves if you
want to lock down you can continue to
lock down
but as we move forward the question is
going to be
why people who are young and healthy
should be locking down and why the
government has the
things that that is a better strategy in
the long run again i talked about this
yesterday
the big question here is going to be and
this is the question no one has yet
answered to my satisfaction
if the area underneath the curve is the
same no matter what you do
but the curve is sharper at the
beginning
which means that less economic damage is
done in the long run
do you want to take the pain now or do
you want to spread it out over the
course of a couple years if nothing
changes
no one has been able to answer this
question for me no one i i'm fully on
board with we can't let it spike so much
that it overwhelms the healthcare system
i'm there i got it
we all get it but again if the curves
have the same area
underneath them if both of them are not
spiking over the line
in the healthcare system if you have one
curve that looks like this
and you have one curve that looks like
this
and the line is the healthcare system
and neither of these curves is going
over the healthcare system
the question becomes which curve do you
want because curve number one right
which is this really heavy bump right
here
has the same area underneath it as curve
number two and curve number two
means that we shut down the economy
basically forever and curve number one
means that we take the pain now and then
we get back into business
the original flattening the curve
situation the key to the flattening the
curve situation
was that in this particular graphic the
dark red the kind of maroon shaded
area right that's the people who would
die needlessly because we don't have the
ability to care for them now as it turns
out even with the ability to care for
people
ventilators didn't help right we were
afraid of ventilators being
in short supply it turns out that 90 of
people on ventilators are dying anyway
but
you don't want the healthcare system
being overwhelmed obviously but take
that line out of the graph
because we have not overwhelmed the
healthcare system if you have the choice
between two curves one
that is sharper at the beginning but
recedes faster and that
lets us go i'll go back to work and back
to ballgames back to movie theaters or
one that lasts a really
long time and has the exact same number
of people who are dead
why would you take the shallower curve
that's the question no one
has been able to answer to my
satisfaction or even presented an answer
to
i don't want to see models honestly i
don't want to see any more models about
how many people are going to die by june
i want to see more models as to how many
people are going to die by a year from
june
those are the ones that i care about why
because when we are talking about
the damage to be done to the american
economy we have to tell how many lives
we are actually saving
and how many people are just having
their deaths delayed by a month or two
because we are flattening the curve just
a little bit
enough to destroy the economy but not
enough to actually save people's lives
over the course of a year
i want to see models that go out a year
from now that's what i want to see even
with uncertainty effects i want to see
what those models look like
and i want to see what those models look
like in the case of controlled avalanche
like
when it's no controlled avalanche it's
just people social distancing and
wearing masks
how about those models why does every
model go a month out
we all know if we release fast more
people will die in the short run but
that's not the question
if you cut off the model right to go
back to my little chart right here
if you cut off the model here and you
say that this
model is june 20 20
and if you go here
and this is june 2021 the charts look
very different
okay the charts look very very different
if you look like this and the mod the
cut finder model is june 2020
obviously you want the the lower curve
right because if you cut off the model
right here what does it look like
that higher curve is a lot of people who
are dead and the lower curve is not as
many people who are dead
now you move it out to june 2021
the same number of people are dead the
same number
the timeline is what matters here and no
one is no one is honestly discussing the
timeline and that is why
if we are going to honestly discuss
policy we don't need models that go out
a month we need models that go out a
year
this is what i've been saying about
sweden the whole time people ripping on
sweden now sweden's really bad because
they're taking the hit in the immediate
term
yes in the immediate term they are
taking the hit correct they're taking
the hit in the immediate term
which means they're not taking the hit
in the long term okay time for some
things i like and then some things that
i hate so
i i will acknowledge that uh there is a
podcast that i really really enjoy
listening to it is a lot of fun it's
called the rewatchables podcast bill
simmons does it over at the ringer
uh and it is kik basically it's him and
a few of his friends
just recapitulating movies that you love
to what he calls watch and re-watch
and uh and i was listening to an episode
the other night about gladiator
and uh this prompted me to actually go
back and watch part of gladiator and
it's pretty fantastic
gladiator it so ridley scott has made
like three
really great movies or he made aliens he
made blade runner he made this i'm not
even a blade runner fan aliens
is a very good movie so this is so
gladiator
is it's become sort of underrated
because for a while it was a little bit
overrated
but the movie is really entertaining it
is like popcorn entertainment at its
finest
here's a little bit of the trailer for
gladiator if you've never seen it
[Applause]
okay so it's like an old school trailer
with no actual voiceover
but you will remove your helmet and tell
me your name
my name is gladiator father to a
murdered son
husband to a murdered wife and i will
have my venues
okay so basically this movie is kind of
like half braveheart half sword and
sandals epic and it's
it's pretty fantastic it's so over the
top and so great and oliver
really choose the scenery apparently
oliver reed and uh
and russell crowe actually nearly came
into a fistfight because that's who
oliver reed was like olivery was sort of
the russell crow of his day he was just
this he was a great actor who was a
total maniac basically and uh and
he died in the making of this film in
fact the original plot of the film was
supposed to have oliver reed fighting
russell crowe after betraying him
right in the in the gladiatorial arena
anyway uh the movie is the movie's fun
so if you're looking for a popcorn flick
tonight go check out gladiator okay time
for some things that i hate
the lack of responsibility of of people
in new york city governance is truly
astonishing i mean really really crazy
so bill de blasio has is not taking on
any sort of onus for the fact that he
completely botched this thing
instead he's blaming the nursing homes
themselves in the state of new york not
the
state of new york law that said that if
a person in your nursing home gets
coveted 19 that they have to be let back
into your nursing home
he's not blaming those p he's not
blaming the law no he's blaming the
nursing homes themselves because
everyone is to blame except bill de
blasio here it was yesterday
there's going to be times where the
nursing home
is the place that can better care if
it's set up that way but remember a lot
of these are for-profit organizations i
think there's gonna be a lot of
questions about whether they put
their residents first or whether they
put profit first
but i'm i don't like what's happening in
the nursing homes i want to see
change but i think in terms of each
individual it's
a case by case you've got to figure out
what's right for each senior
oh well so so it's on the nursing homes
except that we forced the law to
we forced by law them to take back all
these people and so nursing homes become
hot spots for this sort of thing again
protect the nursing homes protect the
nursing homes those are the places where
people are dying on mass
in huge huge numbers meanwhile andrew
cuomo america's governor
is really demonstrating his bona fides
speaking on tuesday new york governor
andrew cuomo reportedly said healthcare
workers who traveled to new york to help
the state's reeling
to help the state reeling from
coronavirus will have to pay state taxes
this is according to hank berry and
daily wire
cuomo stated we're not in a position to
provide any subsidies right now
because we have a 13 billion deficit so
there's a lot of good things i'd like to
do if we get federal funding we can do
but it would be irresponsible for me to
sit here looking at a 13 billion deficit
and say i'm gonna spend more money when
i can't even pay the essential services
you're not spending money that's that's
not your money
those people came in because you asked
them you begged them to come in and help
they came in and helped and now you're
just going to grab their wallet
like this is good governance what the
actual hell
how is that good governance i'm just
wondering what makes this guy so popular
it's astonishing
it truly is how's he able to get away
with being such a garbage governor and
everybody's like oh he's great because
he isn't trump
because he because he'll tell us the
hard truths here's the reality andrew
cuomo when people say well you know he
he's honest he tells us the hard truths
the reason that people on the left are
okay with that is because all those hard
truths they can then blame on trump
if a democrat were president they
wouldn't love andrew cuomo anymore
they'd be talking about how he was
terrible
but because donald trump is president
then everything that cuomo says that the
state of new york is doing right
can be attributed to cuomo and
everything that is bad can be attributed
to trump
and the luckiest person in america that
donald trump is president is andrew
cuomo and the second luckiest is bill de
blasio
because it allows them to shift
responsibility from themselves
to the federal government it's truly an
amazing thing and they they've botched
this thing so poorly in every way
you saw the videos over the last couple
of days of them finally cleaning the
subways
okay that's like me telling my kids to
clean their room they clean the subways
nearly as often as my kid cleans his
room which is to say never
in history it's been like a decade since
they cleaned the subways like oh you
know what maybe we should clean the
subways
yeah in may may you shut down the city
in march and left the subways running 24
hours a day
and you didn't even bother to disinfect
them like once a day well done everyone
well done meanwhile democrats in the
federal government also doing yeoman's
work on behalf of garbage policy
the wall street journal has a good
editorial today talking about
many of the risks of reopening they say
the plaintiff bar is trying to cash in
as really quickly as the coronavirus has
spread trial lawyers are filing suits
against emergency supply manufacturers
for false advertising colleges
for refusal to refund student fees
cruise lines for emotional distress
retailers for wrongful death
nursing homes for negligence and
government for denial of hazard pay
there's little point in lifting
lockdowns if employers don't open for
fear of lawsuits
a number of governors used emergency
powers to grant liability protections to
healthcare workers but trial lawyers
will attempt to get friendly state
courts to invalidate them
most orders also fail to address the
wider economy or novel pandemic related
legal claims
legislation is needed some state
legislatures are moving but the better
answer is for congress to pass legal
protections related specifically to the
pandemic
an economic recovery that set a national
standard and limit the trial bar's
ability to form shop
class actions in friendly state courts
so you should probably eliminate
frivolous lawsuits that don't claim
serious imagery
law firms are already filing lawsuits
against cruise lines arguing that even
passengers that did not contract the
virus were subject to emotional harm and
entitled to punitive damages
businesses are being subjected to the
threat of lawsuit for the
great sin of telling people that they
can come back to work
under circumstances that try to protect
the employees
also we need protections for health
providers including those who are using
new treatments because
everything has to be thrown at the wall
at this point
this is why the white house and senate
republicans want liability protection to
be part of any new virus relief
democrats are opposing this all the way
senate democrats
they do as the wall street journal work
for the lawyers and law firms they've
contributed more than 8 million
to chuck schumer's campaigns from 1.6
million to nancy pelosi's campaign
they've given more than 4 million to the
dscc the democratic senatorial campaign
committee and three million bucks to the
house democratic committee in this
election
cycle so the the addition of liability
on top of all this is going to prevent
business
from opening which is really quite
terrible meanwhile the democrats of
course seem rather sanguine with the
whole lockdown strategy it seems like
they've come up with a political
strategy and that is
we are going to now suggest that
lockdown is the status quo and should be
the de facto status quo
and any attempt to remove lockdown you
can be blamed for each individual death
meanwhile we'll just keep spending which
we wanted to do anyway chuck schumer the
senate minority leader he said that
yesterday he said you know what
mitch mcconnell is balking at more
stimulus we need to keep spending man
let's just keep spending forever let's
just keep doing it
we need big bold action and we need it
soon
we need action to help those who are
unemployed
deal with their lives and not lose
everything their homes their ability to
feed their kids the ability to get
health care
we need to make sure that businesses get
the small businesses get the help that
they need
we need our stake in local governments
which are our firefighters and our
police officers and our bus drivers
we need them not to be laid off and our
republicans friends seem to be twiddling
their thumbs
okay you know swindling their thumbs
people like you who are not providing
any sort of actual standard for
reopening
instead you set these bars that can
never be surpassed and then you're like
well
have you just stopped working toward our
never surpassable bars
if we give out we can reopen ones
everybody in america is given a unicorn
once everybody gets a unicorn we can
reopen
why isn't the federal government working
harder to ensure that everybody gets a
unicorn
let's be real about this nothing is
fundamentally changing here
the testing and tracing stuff
everybody's talking about is designed to
tamp down the hot spots
by the way the first place you're gonna
know the hot spots are emerging is not
actually from the testing and the
contact pricing not when the baseline
level of cases is this high
okay the first place you're gonna know
is when the hospitals start feeling it
it's this this is it's badly calibrated
policy there are no good answers but
democrats have their easy political
answer and that is shut everything down
and then pretend that anybody who dies
is the fault of our political opponents
alrighty we'll be back here a little bit
later today with two additional hours of
content you're listening to the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas directed by mike joyner
executive producer jeremy boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinterton
edited by adam sciavet
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic
is collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton